en août dernier Angèle une octogénaire
avait été victime d'un vol avec violence
par trois adolescents et forts
j'aurais pu vu mes enfants mes
petits-enfants
jugé par le tribunal pour enfants et
reconnu coupable deux désagresseurs
étaient depuis fin novembre maintenu
dans un centre éducatif pour une durée
de 6 mois mais ce matin en colère contre
la justice le maire de Cannes David
Lisnard s'est saisi de son compte
Twitter pour poster ce message
j'apprends que l'un des agresseurs
maintenus en centre éducatif fermé c'est
enfui les forces de l'ordre se mettent
alors à sa recherche et le maire de la
ville finit par publier cet autre tweet
quelques instants plus tard
[Musique]
d'ailleurs à la rentrée tiens d'ailleurs
avant je vous dis un truc à vous dire
c'est incroyable cette histoire
qui nous rejoignent oui donc deux des
trois mineurs l'un ayant été pour le
moment sortir et d'affaires de des 3
mineurs avant de connaître leur peine à
l'été prochain ont été placés dans des
centres éducatifs fermés c'est-à-dire
que là vraiment normalement ça remplace
la prison mais il y a une équipe
éducative c'est clos ils n'ont pas le
droit de sortir ils sont soumis à des
mesures strictes et l'un des deux c'est
évadé parce que c'est le bon mot ce
n'est pas le fils du monsieur qui est
venu sur le plateau c'est l'autre qui
était à Marseille dans un centre fermé
il est parti il a eu envie de retrouver
sa famille il est parti à Cannes et
heureusement le maire de Cannes a réagit
très vite police nationale police
municipale ont travaillé ensemble et il
a été arrêté en pleine ville
interpellé amené dans un commissariat à
Cannes maintenant et il sera présenté à
un juge qui du coup peut décider comme
il n'a pas respecté son contrôle
judiciaire de le placer en prison mais
c'est incroyable sans prédicatif fermé
et il arrive à se partir comme ça parce
qu'il avait envie de revoir sa famille
c'est intolérable ça c'est inadmissible
alors le maire de Cannes j'apprends par
la bande que l'un des agresseurs de la
dame de 80 novembre de Cannes la Bocca
maintenu en centre éducatif fermé sur
décision de justice à plusieurs dizaines
de kilomètres c'est enfui et c'est par
la PM police municipale qu'il est à
Cannes ainsi dans la réalité va la
France j'allais te Gérald Darmanin Eric
Dupond-Moretti pour une action
rigoureuse et que ça détention soit
effectivement appliquée donc contrôler
enfin sur une telle affaire comment le
maire de la commune n'est-il pas informé
par l'état de ce type de situation il
s'agit d'un énième exemple de la
défaillance régalienne française qui
depuis trop longtemps révèle un exécutif
qui n'existe plus qui n'exécute plus un
état souvent impuissant avec les voyous
qui crée un sentiment d'impunité et
alimente donc la crise civique que
traverse notre pays il a été interpellé
ensuite qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
ça Raymond moi je partage David Kelly tu
tues déjà des mecs qui s'évadent des
prisons des vrais prisons la santé
Fresnes partout ils arrivent à s'évader
donc un centre pour éducation
les gars s'évader il s'éveille ça enfui
voilà il faut le rattraper il faut qu'il
fasse à peine parce que là c'est un truc
médiatique mais il y a plein de
d'histoire qui sont pas médiatisées ou
les mecs s'enfuient et on les laisse
après on leur court pas après et on vous
dit moi ici que la jeunesse maintenant
c'est plus un mec de 14 15 16 ans c'est
plus un mec qui a 16 ans dans les années
70 je vous dis aujourd'hui des mecs de
16-17 ans c'est des Coréens il faut
peut-être un peu changer de loi par
rapport à ça peut-être un peu trop
gentil avec le modèle c'est un jeune
c'est un mineur de 7 ans il a rien fait
c'est la faute de qui bah c'est la faute
de personne des mecs qui s'évade même
des propres prisons comment
d'abord j'enlève pas une virgule du
communiqué de Monsieur Lisnard je trouve
qu'il a raison
sauvagement et deux l’impression de
l'axis mais que y a rien qui est
respecté dans notre pays oui une
défaillance de l'État et de l'État de
droit ça c'est la première chose et moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse un audit ou
une enquête sur les centres éducatifs
fermés comment ça fonctionne en France
comment on est surveillé comment on peut
sortir pourquoi il manque de moyens à ce
moment-là qu'on met des moyens mais il y
a pas de raison en fait je ne comprends
pas pourquoi ça ne fonctionne pas voilà
Daniel je sais que tu déjà moi j'ai
envie de vomir par le face matin quand
j'ai eu peur
de justement cette phrase très forte du
maire qui avait dit que c'était arrivé à
sa mère une mère de il aurait sans doute
été en prison parce qu'il serait fait
justice lui-même René le fils de
d'Angèle qui était venu ici avec lui
aussi une réaction très forte en disant
que voilà il savait pas ce qu'il aurait
fait il avait été là parce qu'il savait
très bien que ces jeunes n'auraient pas
grand chose on est en plein dedans et ça
en plus c'est le résultat d'une nouvelle
loi pour les mineurs ou justement on les
met dans des dans des centres fermés
pendant 6 mois pour attendre leur peine
c'est-à-dire que là ils sont déclarés
coupables mais ils sont en attente et on
est même pas capable de les de les
surveiller et il s'échappe c'est voilà
la justice on marche sur la tête et et
les gens vont se faire de plus en plus
ça va être très dangereux les gens vont
se faire de plus en plus justice ça
c'est une nouvelle qui est imaginez ce
sera une circonstance aggravante malgré
tout quand ils auront donc quand il aura
le la peine en juin mais tu vas voir il
va rien avoir ce pauvre petit mais bien
sûr que non Castaldi je trouve que c'est
un problème de justice en deux fois il y
a une première fois on reconnaît les
effets et après dans 6 mois dans huit
mois on va rejeter les gens vont oublier
donc il va y avoir une espèce de la
situation va s'apaiser et je trouve ça
effectivement déplorable qu'on n'attend
pas on ne fasse pas immédiatement
pourquoi attendre 6 mois ça sert à quoi
ça sert à rien du temps
il y a pas d'enquête ils ont été reconnu
coupable on a vu les images tu juges sur
l'instant tu attends pas 6 mois 8 mois
ça sert à quoi à rien alors Guillaume
non mais je suis de base je suis contre
le fait d'envoyer des mineurs
directement en prison en revanche quand
on est dans un centre éducatif fermé qui
a priori ont l'air d'être des passoires
moi j'aimerais bien savoir les règles de
sécurité
de son échapper là en revanche il faut
qu'il aille en prison et tant mieux si
le cas il faut durcir les sanctions
c'est bah alors là il va aller où là
alors là il va être présenté un juge il
soif le renvoyer dans un centre éducatif
fermé un autre peut-être Bordeaux a
l'air plus sûr que celui dont il s'est
échappé à Marseille c'est une maison de
campagne
il y a des gens qui ne sont pas logés
comme ça
en 2002 il y en a une cinquantaine
d'enfants et ça pose problème parce que
ce sont des éducateurs c'est pas des
surveillants de prison alors on me dit
que là c'est direction prison pour
mineur oui c'est très possible à moins
que vous ayez la décision elle va être
prise ce soir mais voilà c'est ça parce
que le juge va dire vous aviez un
contrôle judiciaire vous ne l'avez pas
respecté maintenant en durcit la mesure
et il peut tout à fait mis en prison ce
qu'on évite de faire directement pour
des mineurs mais là pour des
récidivistes ou multirésidivistes
effectivement le juge peut dire c'est la
case prison maintenant vous savez quand
le maire de Cannes s'en prend au
ministre de la Justice là il a raison il
a raison le maire de Cannes là il a été
proactif il a réuni les deux polices la
justice a été très laxiste là-dessus à
mal géré si vous dites on l'envoie pas
en prison vous l'envoyez pas dans un
centre dont il s'évade dont il s'échappe
c'est impossible ça parce que ça va
donner du grain à moudre à tous ceux qui
disent il faut séduire plus amplement et
là ce soir je les comprends moi qui
essaye souvent de d'être un peu
indulgent là il y a aucune indulgence
possible enfin c'est pas le ministre de
la Justice qui tire la porte de
ce que veut dire ce que veut dire le
maire de Cannes Valérie bénaï il m'a
arrêté de debout c'est que la sanction
n'a pas été assez dure c'est tout ce
qu'il dit qu'il aurait il dit qu'il
aurait dû à il s'en prend au système il
dit que la sanction aurait dû être
beaucoup plus dur il dit pas que le mec
le ministre de la Justice est venu
ouvrir la porte il dit juste que voilà
le système est et mauvais que voilà il
fait de s'entraîner pour les mineurs
peut-être lui directement politique
ça fait de la peine pour le pour le
jeune parce que vraiment comment il est
déterminé cette histoire qui a été
médiatisée au possible et lui on veut
faire discret de rester tranquille de
faire sa peine tranquillement dans un
centre il sort il va se remettre dans la
merde pour les c'est catastrophique
d'aller en prison à 16 ans parce que tu
sais pas comment il va ressortir il faut
pas croire que quand tu vas en prison à
16 ans tu ressors et tu passes le bac ça
se trouve il va ressortir encore plus
nerveux tous les plus grands criminels
ils ont été en prison jeune ils sont
ressortis ils ont fait des tas de
conneries derrière donc moi je suis pas
pour la prison à 16 ans et je me dis
mais ce mot-là qu'est-ce qu'il a dans la
tête de ce qu'on sauver et ses parents
et les parents là tu en parles même plus
pour moi ils sont largués les parents là
on en parle même plus des parents là
c'est des gens très dur vraiment
nous quand on avait les témoignages qui
exprimaient qu'il n'avait manifesté
pratiquement aucune empathie pas de
regret une lettre d'excuse qui était pas
écrite par eux donc c'est des gens qui
en ont eu aucune empathie c'est vrai
c'est des gens totalement rupture de la
société le triste la prison
oui voilà des jeunes et c'était validé
un scandale bien sûr un 94% euh voilà et
c'est bien normal